big news while you were sleeping in the
West a dramatic rescue operation
unfolded in Thailand where a youth
soccer team had been trapped in a cave
for more than two weeks Thai Navy SEALs
confirmed that rescuers pulled the last
of 12 boys and their soccer coach out of
that flooded cave this morning it truly
is a miracle we're told all of them are
safe and that is great news
wonderful news the third phase of this
rescue mission started hours ago with
the head of the rescue operation vowing
to get everyone else out eight of the 12
boys were rescued in the first two days
and they're being treated at a local
hospital five hullick health officials
say they're in high spirits and doing
well Anna Werner is near the cave in
Thailand following the rescue effort and
a good morning well it has been an
amazing job performed by these teams
these many rescuers who have come to the
site this third and final day of rescue
as it turned out the divers 19 divers
were going in to rescue the four boys
and their coach who remained in the cave
also with them three tiny Navy SEALs and
a doctor rescue crews worked furiously
to keep the water out of the cave by any
means necessary including plugging
sinkholes on the mountain that let water
in water management is the key to this
whole thing
Tonetta TC helped lead the effort to
remove water from the cave he told us
they faced a critical deadline to get
everyone out before heavy rain in the
forecast Thursday what do you think
people don't understand about the
attempt to manage the water I think
people just the need to realize that you
know it's really hard to keeping out of
the water from the cave we cannot get a
hairy person or even like 50% of it
water drained from the cave helped
reduce the fast-moving current and
allowed the boys to walk in some parts
previously flooded but the path out
still required each boy to swim through
dark narrow passageways flooded with
murky water to divers guided boys while
they held on to a rope one diver in the
front held an oxygen tank and another
was in
back the first four boys emerge from the
cave safely Sunday and four more
followed on Monday most were flown in
helicopters then driven and ambulances
to a Chiang Rai Hospital nity see says
getting all the boys out safely means
everything to Thailand what was it like
for you to see those first kids come out
I will emotional yeah all my team are
you know one we heard the news all my
team just cry but we've working so hard
but a past Friday and it's just finally
seeing it happens yeah that's something
now all of those boys are expected to be
staying in the hospital for seven days
time media is reporting that some
parents actually have seen their kids
they had to stay two metres away and
wear face masks that was for the first
group of four kids for the second group
of four kids their parents also saw them
but only through a glass wall John how
happy those parents must be and the
entire world swiveled its head to look
at at this give us some scope of the
operation there well you know it's a
worldwide operation at this point that's
what it became right you have a thousand
people who've been working here that
doesn't even include the volunteers who
showed up to help and where do these
people come from from all over the world
essentially the United States the UK
China Japan Finland Belgium Australia
just some of the companies that pitched
in ninety divers the top divers from
around the world and all of them with a
single mission to save this one soccer
team and their coach the global effort
really joining forces there and I can
you tell us what went into the process
of deciding which boys were coming out
first was that the strongest or was it
the weakest because we've been hearing
conflicting reports so what we heard
initially was that they were bringing
the strongest boys out first and the
weakest last I suppose that that would
build up the strength of the weakest
boys but we do want to hear more about
that decision-making process because
although we did get those tidbits we
didn't really get a methodical
understanding of how to organize
and who comes out first second third all
of that so we're hoping to hear more
from officials either tonight tomorrow
in the coming days on how all of this
played out beyond Anna thank you